bientôt diffusé aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur police d'agir depuis deux
mois dans - bio qui jouit aujourd'hui on
se trouve sur all is thus d'un petit jeu
d'horreur totalement gratuite start
c'est parti c'est l'histoire d'un
fermier dans les années attends attends
je vous fais agresser le bagas et dans
les années 1900 28 vers 22h47 très
précis ont manqué aucun accident
les sensations étaient présentes c'est
l'histoire d'une fille qui se baladait
dans un champ déjà au maine mais un
articule fait un effort on dirait que tu
es sous l'oeil qui est ton jeu bordel
apparemment il est c'est le papa de
cette petite fille et je crois qu'il
disait que
voilà on est fermier par des familles
c'est quoi comme je dois fermer la terre
un petit peu c'est cool c'est joli ça va
ça te ça passe très bien
alors qu'il faut faire au j'ai vu un
truc assez indécent d'une petite fille à
qui benoît ok je file avec cette lenteur
dans les bars ça c'est clair et net
c'est clarinette aux chiefs au sprint n
follows de gosse et garde donc match
archives pour courir et suit le fantôme
meuse une superbe idée il ya un fantôme
ah oui le combat à la lanterne et ont
suivi fortune olalalala vient là je vais
toucher tu seras cher espèce veuve non
il va se chercher à se cacher non là on
pourra plus touchées island puis
d'accord donc y manque la manivelle
apparemment pour monter ce [ __ ] de
filles donc je pense que le fantôme mais
là son cadavre qui est profondément dans
ce puits donc je trouve une manivelle
voilà et ça me donne envie de chanter et
moi pendant ce temps-là tourner la bête
la manivelle doit donc chance et ça bien
sûr regardez moi dans les fougères comme
ça nous dit totalement vulnérable monde
et une charrette renversé est-ce que la
manivelle serait là dedans manivelle
montre-toi manille quand je vais me
laisser tenter par un [ __ ] de pigeons
attend à ce qu elle est directe ok fois
dans plus d'un des graines souvent j'ai
des petites bêtes de pages donne le
quignon du pain à dos mais je peux aller
où je veux c'est vraiment trouve la
manivelle points est ce que ce serait la
manivelle
il s'agit d'un bâtiment avec aucune
entrée au jaï où je dois aller je ne
sais pas je parle avec des fougères en
voilà on a tous un sport le spot pourri
quoi [ __ ] la punition le cash on
l'appelle tiens c'est la porte avant de
la grange est bien est ce que je peut
l'ouvrir sévit depuis des mois
maintenant des rats se trouve toujours à
l'intérieur depuis que j'ai fermé mais
c'est super et la pareille oh là là mais
pourquoi ils créent des endroits dans
lesquels on ne peut pas aller je
comprends pas à temps mais ça c'est tout
court ça soit la manivelle elle est dans
la maison
hays est le journal quotidien juste là
le quinze de 1929 la police a signalé le
kidnapping d'une fille de 7 ans et c'est
ma fille c'est ça ma fille patricia
zuoming la porte est fermée
satané patricia est ce qu'on va prendre
cette poêle pour là on peut rien prof
peut juste brûler [ __ ] de manivelle
une manivelle dans un foyer une
manivelle
non là la porte non sa femme énervée
oh mon dieu on a trouvé un chemin je
sens qu'on se dirige vers la manivelle
elle est proche mais allez me koubbi l'a
pas d'endurance est incroyable voilà
trois fois ça se met au bac il a eu un 1
sur 20 c'est une légende
oh c'est quoi ça va serait ce la manif
belle lalalalalala aa c'est quoi c'est
quoi m'a fait peur moi j'étais là comme
ça devant une croix joyet nourou par
terre c'était cool on chantait du manu
on s'éclatait il est terrifiant j'ai
besoin de cette roue alors tu vas vite
et me casser les steaks maintenant je
suis gentil je suis gentil j'ai pris la
roue je regarde le dessin aaa
c'était du simple on a trop fumé hier
[ __ ] c'est tout avant il y avait ma
nuque était là et tourner la manivelle
c'est faux que j'arrêtais de bach ou
gerra plus jamais on est ok ok elle
avait une ration de type militaire avec
sa poupée et apparemment elle est morte
à méchante et un truc qui me collait un
peu c'est comme dans le bus scolaire ou
du monde à dessein mais [ __ ] mais je
les aie a un truc à bouger il ya un truc
à bouger dans les poches dans les poches
[ __ ] je suis en train de faire quand
tu veux trop bas ah si c'est bon ou qui
y bossent à la manivelle haut on sait
jamais une claire
c'est là que c'est la clé de la chambre
de patricia loeb patricia store as-tu
akale médias écrits en rouge comme ça en
faisant peur juste sur comment va la
peinture à un monceau dans le lit avec
la perruque de patricia comme ça bonjour
papa le mousse qui veut une nouvelle vie
allez au loch a est ce que c'est ça ans
patricia auriez c'est le signe là qu'on
voit partout degré il ya des gens qui
sont venu toquer j'ai rien compris à ce
qu'il a dit ensuite puis ensuite ils
sont revenus toqués [ __ ] ils ont donné
ce livre voilà après celle to pick up
paige alors qu'est-ce qu'elle 17 km elle
parle d' hélène je crois hélas tu payes
mais pourquoi je peux pas je peux pas
vache vous baise voyait la panda granger
est ouverte maintenant et ouais elle
n'était pas ouverte tout à l'heure au
lac et a assisté le canard c'est bon
j'ai peur j'ai peur je le sens pas du
tout du tout du pardon qu'est-ce qui est
un monstre d'amnesia the dark descent
fait là il va me sauter dessus [ __ ]
escale à l'eau monte et attention c'est
bon qu'est ce qu'on a ici mais c'est
bien c'est très glauque j'adore
s'étendre aux mines page fragments un
ouais waouh diritti on se fait attaquer
par hit i o o attend sa manière de
marcher
tu m'as choix à domicile et nul à mon
dieu c'était pas là avant on peut monter
howie fragments de ils dansent un peu
regardé bombe à des styles des chiens
l oit la véritable histoire de superman
au mais sont terrifiantes
alors ensuite on doit aller à chaque
spot pour prendre un petit fragment de
pages mais ça c'est plutôt réputé dans
le milieu et moi voilà je cueillais la
fougère ab je me ferais jamais déjà
regarde pas il marche on les entend
lâche quitte la map là tu continue tout
droit et arrive sur ou mirror's edge
non mais là je quitte l'endroit sans
déconner et moi pendant ce temps là je
tourne et la met à boire à mes genoux
pêche poubelles et on fait du mail avec
non mais oh qu'est le gall fait du krav
maga quoi moi j'en suis à ma première
année de judo qui tu que je fasse hop et
le troisième à mon avis à des jeux lire
des conneries que j'ai une carte aussi
voilà en passant à je pense que
d'appeler ce signe rouge en il reste à
la charrette là là dans le champ tout
droit ce parti génial ce wagon était
abandonné depuis que mon dernier cheval
est mort oui c'est truqué
ayano qui va bloquer non on aurait dit
une note bruxelles ou en fait y'a rien
c'est trop de larnack à 6 voilà donc là
on avait trois fragments pour tourner à
la maison on est bien d'accord à leur
tour dans la maison aux laquais talent
voilà c'est parti
ok oss ou fatigué par une sorte de secte
apparemment je crois regardez là il ya
plein de mecs de saïdi j'ai ouvert la
porte et j'ai vu ses fils de tout autour
de la ferme
et voilà ils ont foutu le feu partout
avec des croix partout mais cher en jeu
et bah écoutez on va sortir de là allez
on s'en va à temps à attendre dans le
mail ils ont juste ramener chaque croix
fait genre 150 kg il en aura des 18 quoi
mais qui n'était pas trop organisé déjà
en mode yeux un petit cube volant c'est
patricia nos relations mais bon les gars
comment on s'en va a dit moi à la fin là
au [ __ ] voyage indiqué c'est entre le
moulin et le puy hockey a attrait à ba
moi aussi what
[Musique]
il n'a pas le temps il s'en va les
steaks par là en fait je pense voilà
tard oh là là le fou il omet qui fait un
faux chemin avec un portail fermé au
bout mais il n'a pas honte
ok on arrive dans l'endroit le plus
lourd du monde c'est parti pour voir ces
gros bidon rate locaux voilà vous
réparez pas les pots cassés
c'est pas le moment on n'en reste plus
qu'un tout est au ralenti lui coûtent
tès balayette hop on cache le pot aux
mondiaux
le fantôme est là au revoir les hits i
je vous aimais patricia deux voitures se
sont rentrés dedans avec quelqu'un qui
est mort à côté c'est patricia donc
c'est comme ça qu'elle est morte dans la
forêt toute seule se fait renverser par
une voiture
si je comprends bien mais elle avait le
signe sur la main il avait infecté ou
alors j'allais compris un procès pabois
laval et je suis pas de cette vidéo ça
vous a plus sega n'hésitez pas à aller
mais comme d'habitude va pour un jeu
gratuit il est pas mal du tout bonnes du
tout bois jeux gratuits y pas mal et il
est là écoutez c'est pas mal après
j'avoue que mon niveau enfin le mec
parler vraiment comme un américain qui
vit dans une ferme avec sa fille
effectivement il a bien fait donc du
coup j'avais beaucoup de mal à
comprendre et je vais les mêmes éléments
ce qui ressemblait haïti et puis bon le
fameux concept du dès que je regarde pas
le monstre me suis dit je vais retourner
s'arrête le 1 2 3 soleil concept on
connaît bien énorme à la soeur de ce qui
était en son tour à tour dans une
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
tient tout le monde le pis
[Musique]